[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been pumping at this for two hours
and eight minutes there's something
wrong it's not holding air look at that
what did that that's not a clean cut
that's like an abrasion tear well I just
got off the phone with customer support
they're gonna send me a new one to start
it tomorrow I'm gonna ship back that old
one and we're gonna try this again in a
few days all right
boat just sent me a replacement dock
let's go give it this another try
back to the river
all right we're back and this time our
raft does it have a hole in it at least
not yet one lesson I learned last time
is that the electric pump is worth every
penny all right while the raft is
inflating me and the boys are looking
for helga mites and crawdads and we're
just having a ball and check this out I
found the biggest helga mine ever he's
so creepy look at that
that thing is massive
look at the size of him it's like the
critter from Rapa Khan oh there's a dead
one look at that he's big enough to eat
are you having fun I'm already seeing
bass and some really big sucker fish we
got some bait we might be doing a catch
and cook video here a little bit later
[Music]
this push is easy all right guys you
ready to do this all right we're gonna
go spend the next two days on this River
and I am excited huh whoa all right you
guys ready for this
all aboard all right we're doing this
just thing handles like a dream it is so
easy to maneuver it bends a little bit
but this thing is rock solid is this fun
yes this is so cool are you gonna get a
paddle us we got Huck Nate and Tom
nickel
so this pole I'm using the push is 16
feet long it's just a couple two by twos
we're taking a table saw and I've ripped
the corners off them to make it kind of
like a letter octagon or whatever and we
just couple them together with a piece
of 2-inch PVC pipe screw right through
the middle to keep it together and this
is my push Pole and just in case it
breaks I've got another one right there
as a backup I floated this river a
couple of times without the boys on
storage bin rafts that I made they're
really similar in design to the floating
fishing cabin we made it a couple months
ago
that's an awesome video if you haven't
seen that by the way I'm gonna pull out
the fishing rod real quick whenever I
get a little downtime between steering
I'm trying to do some fishing if we
catch something decent we'll do a little
catch and cook tonight
blowing it Oh a little breeze kicked up
and it actually blew us upstream about
15 feet
this thing is so light on the water it
just gets pushed around really easy well
the winds push it against the current a
little bit but if I sit down it seems to
cut our profile enough where we head
back down streams anything you're
getting good at that this raft is only
eight inches thick and we're not even
halfway submerged so we we got less than
four inches of draft on this thing we
can go shallow
oh that's the way kid hey Thomas what do
you think about going over your first
waterfall I made a huge mistake well
guys I hope you like that cuz we're
gonna be going down some even bigger
Rapids here a little bit we're gonna go
through the squeeze a little class three
action for us well it is a beautiful 85
degrees today and Nathan's wants to go
swimming here yeah is the water cold
[Music]
one of the things I've learned from
experience is that you don't ever put
the pole downstream okay because you
shove it into the rocks and it get stuck
or you don't move it quick enough the
raft runs it over it'll it'll pull the
pole out of your hands or it will snap
the pole
you always push to the side or upstream
there we go hold on tight
it turns out if you just lay down on the
ground
and do nothing that then the wind can't
push the bonus budget we got dinner well
we put in some good miles but we need to
start thinking about camping and so we
need to look for a campsite someplace
it's flat and has a lot of wood because
we want to build a fire oh look at that
all right let's check this place out
well this looks pretty good it's not
super flat but I think it's flat enough
and we got piles of wood up in the trees
and we can burn that so let's start
gathering some wood for fires
all right guys where we gonna build a
fire yeah right there looks pretty good
down there all right
oh boy I turned my back for one second
and he falls out of a tree geez you okay
real simple trick here I've got cotton
balls soaked in Vaseline I put one
underneath there put one on the end of a
stick and then I use my flint and steel
to go and ignite the one and then get it
under there
I've got a decent little fire going well
let that mature and we'll be cooking a
little bit
well the biggest white water on this
whole trip is a set of class-three
Rapids called the squeeze and I was a
little vague on where it was but as I'm
sitting here oh there it is
that's the entrance to the squeeze so
looks like first thing in the morning
we're gonna be taking this raft down
some class-three Rapids that's gonna be
fun yeah you want to squeeze yeah all
right we're gonna boil some water get
dinner going here all right boys why
don't you come over here and show me
what you want to eat for dinner tonight
we have Italian style pepper steak and
noodles and chicken
time to eat our meager catch all right
we're gonna try eating fall fish tonight
yeah
Nathan you like your chicken noodles
yeah yeah they fixed it for you all
right there we go
Italian pepper steak our little fall
fish is coming along nicely all right
who wants to eat some fish and take a
little bit of skin off or got a lot of
Bo he grabbed a piece of a lot of bones
in it what do you think does it taste
any good pretty nondescript tastes like
many other white fish I've eaten it just
as easily be a grayling skins pretty
good well would you guys like some hot
chocolate
yeah sure are you guys like that
[Applause]
all right yeah it's gonna be so as a
dressing for winter camping you want to
watch a movie all right cold wet shoes
worse Tommy you want to stay there tell
you at the fair going we're gonna mix it
up a little bit I got a package of
birthday candles here and we're gonna
use that to start the fire there you go
a little birthday candle fire Tommy are
you having a good time yeah are you glad
you came we got chorizo flavored spam
today we're gonna give that a try for
breakfast
who wants to try the tree so spam you
know it tastes it tastes like if you mix
chili with spam smells like chili to
your forked knife look at this nothing
screams America like a folding fork and
spoon set look at the cool part about
this tencel's come apart yeah look at
that
there's Nathan's folding fork and spoon
set all right guys you ready to go down
to squeeze
[Applause]
what do you think of that Nathan well
maybe we'll have to do some more
whitewater rafting in this thing okay
yeah but this raft is so big it just
kind of it doesn't matter which
direction you go down and you just he
just go down and hold on did the only
thing you have to worry about is hitting
the trees and having sweepers knock your
gear off ah today is lovely it's sunny
it's warm and no wind that wind was
killing us yesterday no this is gonna be
great Bob are used to living yeah I can
be my boat motor
[Music]
[Music]
I love this thing the draft on this is
so shallow did you like that I think the
boys just discovered their new favorite
thing whitewater rafting guys you want
me to go swimming oh no guys it's a
leech here you go
so one of the key techniques is putting
your feet in the dead center when the
feet are in the center and you push any
direction the raft moves in that
direction if you stand on the edge the
raft will spin more centered you are the
less of your energy gets put into
spinning and more into steering right
now it's too deep to use the pole so you
can just kind of use it like a kayak it
actually works really well a lot of
smallmouth bass last time I went here
you're getting better
[Music]
[Applause]
what a heck of a way to travel this is
so nice I gotta tell you what I am
really pleased with this inflatable dock
so far and I definitely think we're
gonna be doing some more trips like this
this is just too much fun if you guys
want to learn more about this thing I'll
put a link in the description to their
website you guys can check it out let's
go here alright guys this looks like a
good spot as any to make lunch you guys
find a nice little swimming hole alright
well the boys are swimming and playing I
am gonna prepare a Nathan's favorite
meal cup of noodle there we go
well that water's boiling let me show
you something cool see all these rocks
down here amongst the trees this is a
big bend in the river when the river
floods the water and current comes
straight through these trees and it acts
like a sieve so all the debris and stuff
that gets washed into the river get
stuck up in here look at all this stuff
yeah it's a soccer ball yeah yeah baby
look at this this is just a mountain of
flotsam and there's like another soccer
ball or something over there look at
this how far it goes last week the water
was 16 feet deep and so where you were
standing was underwater the river was
flowing right where you're standing and
all this stuff hit up against the trees
and got stuck here that's how it ended
up in this big pile look at this look at
the size of that stump man that thing's
huge
this is why you cannot be on the river
when it's flooding because you'll end up
getting washed into these forests and
then you get stuck in there you never
come out nothing keeps these boys more
entertained than playing in the water
you guys like your swimming hole well
the boys are really complaining about
being hungry so I pulled over and I made
them their their favorite thing and they
haven't eaten they're just over there
fishing best part isn't just getting
along and having a good time together as
brothers it's the best they need a
little bro time I'm just gonna sit here
and eat my food and let them do their
thing all right guys you ready go all
right
Wow
[Music]
oh this has been fun sure hope our good
weather holds out we may or may not get
some rain storms here in a few hours so
we'll see
look at those haunted trees guys yeah
those things are creepy lookit look at
that one you can hide inside you like
take a bath inside that tree look at
that tree yeah look at that huge thing
owner how high you can climb up inside
that thing
oh that's so much fun and it takes zero
skill and this thing just do we got a
jump out of that tree
Nathan you excited try that you ought to
try that table all right you want to get
my back hold on just high enough you
wanna go higher date well jump just jump
right off there there you go buddy
Nathan was that fun it's my turn oh I
thought I was just carrying Nathan up
did you like that okay go down oh there
we go Tom hey can I see it that's a
pullout spot
no ward look guys did you have a good
time I hope you guys enjoyed watching
this as much as we enjoyed making this
video don't forget to check out our
other videos including our floating
fishing cabin video our abandoned Island
camping video and a lot of other stuff
I'll put links in the description don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning thanks for
watching guys if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that belt
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching woo we got off the river
just in time boys